in der letzten Folge haben wir zuerst
den Porsche den wir uns über neuen
Folgen in Porsche Trader bearbeitet
haben gekauft und euch dann erklärt was
wir alles umbauen wollen aber nicht nur
erklärt sondern auch direkt damit
angefangen wir haben ihn einmal komplett
auseinander genommen um ihm vorne und
hinten fast 50 mm höher zu legen die
neue frischpulverbeschichtete Hackmesser
Felgen und deutlich dickere Reifen
verpasst und euch erklärt wie ihr das
Auto gewinnen könnt und das ist im
Prinzip ganz einfach über den Link in
der Videobeschreibung
www.meck.losing kommt ihr in den
thermikshop und jeder Euro den ihr dort
umsetzt ist ein Los für den Lostopf um
den umgebauten Porsche 944 die meisten
Sachen sind leider schon nur noch in
wenigen größten verfügbar also check das
aus und seid schnell wenn ihr mitmachen
wollt es gibt aber auch noch eine Option
wie ihr mitmachen könnt ohne einen Euro
auszugeben und das über die Thermik
Instagram Seite die auch in der
Videobeschreibung findet dort gibt es
einen Gewinnspiel den müsst ihr liken
der Seite folgen drei Freunde in den
Kommentaren markieren und den Beitrag in
eurer Story teilen und ihr seid mit fünf
entrys also so als hättet ihr 5 € im
Shop ausgegeben mit im Gewinnspiel viel
Glück beim Gewinnspiel und jetzt
brauchen wir das Auto gemeinsam weiter
wir waren von vorne rein klar dass das
Auto nicht so knallrot bleiben soll wie
es original mal ausgeliefert wurde das
Auto wird grün und zwar ein richtig
geiles Grün das perfekt zum Offroad
Charakter passt damit wir das aber
machen können damit wir das Auto
verlieren können gibt es einiges an
Vorarbeit erstmal muss alles abgenommen
werden was nicht mit verliert werden
soll oder uns bei der Folierung stört
meine Karre jetzt sauber dann kann
poliert werden
[Musik]
nach 38 Jahren ist das an manchen
Stellen aber gar nicht so einfach das
wirklich gründlich zu reinigen gerade
die Dichtung waren jahrelang in der
Sonne im Dreck im Regen und haben sich
quasi mit dem Auto verbunden also was
übelst krass ist hier so scheiß
Dichtmasse die mega ab nervt übelst
klebt die komplett weg muss einmal aber
sie hat funktioniert also das Auto ist
jetzt aber 38 Jahre alt und es ist an
wichtigen Stellen keinen Rost also blind
richtig gekauft in mühevoller
Kleinarbeit haben wir also jede kleine
Ecke des Autos einmal gründlich
gereinigt denn alles was wir nicht
entfernen sieht man nachher durch die
Folie und sieht wirklich scheiße aus man
kann also nicht gründlich genug sein so
kann es sauber ganz kurzfristig ähm aus
der Umgebung gefunden sehr nett vielen
Dank alle Links dazu in der
Videobeschreibung in den nächsten Tagen
machen wir noch voll Folierung auf
gesamte Auto und jetzt testen an der
Motorhaube erstmal an ob das denn so
funktioniert mit der Folie die ich
bestellt habe und damit kommen wir auch
zum real der Farben ich glaube es wird
einen Gefallen mit Neid green ein
unheimlich dunkles kräftiges
metallic-gründen des quasi so aussieht
als hätte man direkt aus dem Wald
genommen
das in Kombination mit den Golden Felgen
ist der Stoff aus dem Träume gemacht
sind
wenn die Farbe Papagei junge die Farbe
ist eine absolute zehn von zehn ja wie
ihr seht
Kartons so hoch gestapelt wie ich groß
bin ungefähr Front Runner hat uns
ausgestattet mit einer Menge Menge Kram
den wir uns jetzt gemeinsam anschauen
wir machen den ganzen Kram jetzt mal
leer schauen wie der Dachgepäckträger
montiert wird und was sie überhaupt
alles drin ist weil es ist eine Menge
wir haben das hier sieht für mich aus
wie die Verpackung der Stühle Emaille
Teller aber das ist das komplette
Besteckset ja komplettes Camping
Besteckset Osram Lampen für den
Dachgepäckträger noch mehr
Lampenhalterung Halterung dreifache
Schrauben Spektakel jetzt eins der
Highlight Design technisch aber auch
funktional die an die Seite vom
Dachgepäckträger kommen Sandbleche fährt
man sich irgendwo festlegt man die
unteren Reifen fährt wieder raus richtig
richtig geil Campingtisch so flach dass
er zwischen Dachgepäckträger und Dach
vom Auto rein geschoben werden kann so
Halterung 20 Liter Wasserkanister in
diesem kleinen Paket sind zwei Stühle
zwei wurfzelte in kleinem Packmaß
noch mehr Osram Lampen ist ein bisschen
doof die 7 Zoll Osram Lampen waren nicht
lieferbar deswegen haben wir jetzt 10
Zoll
ach du scheiße unsere Schaufel für die
wir gerade eben schon eine Halterung
gefunden haben in ähnlichem grün wie
unser Auto ja jetzt eins meiner
Highlights Front Runner pro wolf pack
eine der Kisten hier oben auf dem
Dachgepäckträger kommen und eine Menge
Platz für allerlei Kram und jetzt zum
wichtigsten Part den wir essenziell
brauchen um überhaupt was mit dem
anderen kam am Anfang zu können unser
Dachgepäckträger der für den 9 24 und
944 gedacht und gebaut ist das ein
absoluter Traum ist vielen vielen Dank
an Front Runner die uns all das hier zur
Verfügung gestellt haben unbezahlte
Werbung ich bedanke mich vielmals das
ist der Part der das Auto wirklich zu
einem Offroad Auto werden lässt und mehr
Funktionalität bringen auf der Suche
waren wir nach sieben Zoll Scheinwerfern
die waren leider nicht 10 Zoll und die
sehen so aus ja ähm na ja machen wir
zwei nach vorne zwei nach hinten wenn
die mir zu einer auffahren mache ich
einmal volle Pulle nach hinten an
[Musik]
auf der Autobahn im Dunkeln einmal nach
hinten guck mal das ist eigentlich die
normale Größe
aber jetzt erstmal Mittagspause und die
sieht bei Rennen Klasse etwas anders aus
als bei gewöhnt vielen Dank Pause
Mittagspause bei Rennklasse bedeutet
dieses freaky Card fahren oder wir wie
heißt das Crazy Card und alle Jungs
haben ihr eigenes Kart und dann sieht
das so aus kommen die so um die Kurve
hier am Bodensee ist der Zusammenbau des
Dachgepäckträgers wir haben gerade schon
ein bisschen getestet ich zeige euch mal
wie das aussieht die Halterungen sind
nämlich schon zusammengeschraubt sind
diese vier hier hier so zack
reingeklemmt dann wird das zugemacht
dann steht das hier der Dachgepäckträger
drauf und alle sind happy und um den
Dachgepäckträger dann direkt für das zu
nutzen wofür eigentlich gedacht ist
nämlich um beladen zu werden haben wir
alles montiert was von frontrolle
mitgeschickt wurde
und wie ihr seht das ganze Team also
wirklich jeder hat an irgendeiner Stelle
gearbeitet und sich immer wieder neue
Arbeit gesucht denn anders er ist gar
nicht möglich gewesen wir haben nur noch
vier Tage bis zur Rallye und es darf
nichts schief gehen und das will ich
hier kurz einwerfen das ist nicht
abgesprochen dass das jetzt sage aber
dieser Dachgepäckträger und das System
ist ein absoluter Traum das ist so ein
bisschen belego und völlig egal wie groß
ihr denn nachträger bestellt also für
ein Range Rover für ein Porsche alle
Sachen passen auf alle Dachgepäckträger
das ist immer das gleiche System es gibt
unendlich viele Möglichkeiten verrückte
und nützliche Dinge daran zu montieren
z.B haben wir auch einen Flaschenöffner
an die Seite gemacht irgendwann war es
auch Zeit die Lampen zu montieren und
als sie montiert waren sie gar nicht
mehr so viel zu groß aus um ehrlich zu
sein dann sieht ziemlich passend und
ziemlich geil aus eine Sache hat mich
dann aber doch noch gestört auch wenn es
nur ein Detail ist die Farbe also
kurzerhand in den Baumarkt gefahren und
Grundierung unten knalliges Raum zu
holen damit wir die Schaufel habe ich
den Sandflächen anpassen können hier auf
der anderen Seite vom Autor die alten
also die Signalen Sitze waren eigentlich
gar nicht so alt der Vorbesitzer hat sie
nämlich professionell neu beziehen
lassen mit roten Nähten und das sah
alles schon wirklich gut aus aber wenn
wir schon mal dabei sind und das Rallye
Auto unserer Träume bauen wollen dann
brauchen wir auch Release Sitze
beziehungsweise Sitze die nach Rennen
aussehen aber so komfortabel sind dass
wir auch mehrere tausend Kilometer damit
fahren ich wollte einfach neue Sitze
haben also habe ich kurze Hand Recaro
Sports dass die Äste zum bestellt der so
ziemlich schönste sitzt den man after
market in so ziemlich jedes Auto
einbauen kann indem man den renn
Charakter haben will und das nicht
normal sondern mit Fake Wildleder weil
das deutlich besser zum Lenkrad passt
und einfach nur aussieht um diese Sitze
montieren zu können brauchen wir aber
auch neue Schienen die haben eine
angebracht angepasst dann konnten
eingebaut werden
sitzt so gut und das macht den Innenraum
so modern mit Bluetooth Mucke laufen
lassen Fenster runter Heizung volle
Pulle bei 30 Grad damit der Motor nicht
überhitzt und dann schön
krass
richtig krass Tag zwei wahnsinnig
erfolgreich
war nämlich genau das Gegenteil von Tag
2 wir haben unheimlich viele unheimlich
wichtige Aufgaben gemacht von denen man
deutlich weniger gesehen hat aber Sie
müssen eben gemacht angefangen
die wurden direkt an die Karosserie
geschraubt und sind dafür das Auto vor
Steinen und Dreck zu schützen vor allem
weil wir wirklich im Offroad unterwegs
sein wollen weiter ging es mit den
Frontstrahler die Turbo Front hat von
sich aus vier Lufteinlässe in die diese
viereckigen hehlerlampen perfekt
reinpassen und auch hierfür musste Marc
wie bei der Heckstoßstange wieder sich
eine eigene Lösung bauen also ausmessen
liegen Schweißen befestigen Löcher
bohren in die Halterung dann die Lampen
final montieren
glücklicherweise haben wir aber alles
getestet bevor wir es montiert haben
eine der Lampen kam nämlich komplett tot
out of the box die mussten also
austauschen neu bestellen und konnten
dann alles final montieren auch an der
Baseball also der Heckstoßstange wurde
weitergearbeitet die wurde abgeschliffen
Sachen wurden ausgebessert die Final
schwarz lackiert und wo wir schon beim
Baseball und den grandiosen sehr
kurzfristigen Ideen von Markus sind dann
wird dort auch direkt weitermachen wir
haben doch gestern gesagt machen können
wenn wir die Rückbank umklappen lassen
sich gerade eingefallen haben
richtig toll sieht aus wie ein ziemlich
großer BH ein neues Netz zwischen
Fahrerkabine und Kofferraum das dem Auto
ein viel krasseren Rally Charakter gibt
außerdem haben wir die porösen
Benzinleitung erneuert und neue
Lautsprecher eingebaut was mir
unheimlich wichtig war denn das Auto
soll sich nicht nur neu anfühlen sondern
es muss auch irgendwie dem technischen
Standard so ein bisschen gerecht werden
ich glaube gerade hier hinten die
Verkleidung ab vier Lautsprecher haben
wir insgesamt zwei vorne zwei hinten die
werden alle ausgetauscht damit wir mit
bestem Sound durch Europa Pass nature
Fach im Prinzip Plug and Play und würde
ich sagen ein sehr wichtiges Upgrade für
so ein altes Auto als schlechten Sound
kann niemand gebrauchen und übertönt
vielleicht die Lautstärke der sehr
großen Reifen
so zum Geburtstag
viel Glück
Nummer vier ist nicht nur Tag Nummer 4
raus sondern auch Markus geburtstag der
das quasi alles für mich möglich und das
beste mag der Werkstattleiter den ihr
auch schon kennengelernt habt hat zwei
Tage später Geburtstag das lag so
perfekt dass ich wusste ich muss mir
irgendwas einfallen lassen einmal bitte
zur Porschestraße 1 in Leipzig
es gibt eine Porsche Teststrecke wo die
Autos wirklich in die Mangel genommen
werden und passiert das aber mal an
einigen Tagen nicht werden Leute wie
Markus und Mark mit Autos Ihrer Wahl von
Porsche die Strecke gelassen genau das
haben wir gemacht
[Musik]
Markus und Marx sind auf der Strecke ich
bin schrecklich neidisch aber man
munkelt das ist Grund für mich gibt bald
noch mal wieder zu kommen und selber zu
fahren leider gab es noch zwei Plätze
bedeutet für mich ich muss von außen zu
gucken und die Jungs dürfen Spaß haben
aber bei der harten Arbeit 10 12 Stunden
am Tag in der Werkstatt mit mir um
dieses Projekt irgendwie für mich und
für euch in so kurzer Zeit auf die Beine
zu stellen war das Meer als verdient
mega geil und während die Jungs Runde
umrunde gedreht haben ging es in der
Werkstatt schon weiter anton hat sich um
alles gekümmert was mit Elektrik zu tun
hatte also Sicherung getauscht neue
Kabel verlegt und neue Schalter für
beide Lampen also vorne in der Front und
oben am Dachgepäckträger installiert
wir haben 11:30 Uhr also heller geht's
tageslichtmäßig nicht und diese Lampen
sind noch mal so viel heller als das was
die Sonne jetzt gerade liefert was hier
drin in der Garage angekommen
[Musik]
und ein weiteres Highlight bekommen zum
Lenkrad the big Moment
gerade inklusive einer Besonderheit wo
wir gleich noch zu sprechen kommen
ja fühlt sich an als wird das Auto
dadurch mehr PS bekommen dadurch dass
das Original Lenkrad kein Airbag drin
hatte ist sowas problemlos möglich hat
man ein Auto mit Airbag geht sowas
natürlich nicht und jetzt zum final
touch geschenkt von Markus ich hoffe ihr
kommt hinterher mit Mark und Markus
damit ich immer weiß wo das Auto
herkommt
[Musik]
schaut euch das an
die Porsche Trader
außerdem waren die Jungs und Mädels von
GW Design schon den ganzen Tag damit
beschäftigt das Auto in absoluter
Präzisionsarbeit perfekt
[Musik]
so wir ziehen jetzt die Folie ab wird
sich darum gedrückt wer das machen muss
weil das ein stromschock gibt deswegen
mache ich das jetzt von mir für euch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und das will ich auch noch mal sagen
folieren hat für mich von außen immer so
ausgesehen als wäre das jetzt kein
Hexenwerk aber was damit alles
zusammenhängt und wie genau man arbeiten
muss fahren wir bis dato nicht bewusst
um genau zu sein musst mir die
folierungsarbeiten noch mit in den
nächsten Tag nehmen weil wir das
Ergebnis wirklich perfekt haben wollen
und damit kommen wir zur Takt den
letzten Tag vor der Rally zum Glück ist
die ersatzleuchte für die Turbo Front
noch genau und time angekommen die haben
wir eingebaut und getestet
boah Alter Maul Alter
diese kleine Lichtleiste lässt das Auto
so viel krasse aussehen und lässt es
wirklich zu einem Offroad und Rally
character passen was aber noch mehr dazu
beiträgt sind die großen Lampen oben auf
dem Dachgepäckträger aber auch diese
Lampen brauchen Strom und dafür haben
wir ein Kabel einmal komplett durch den
Innenraum gelegt so dass es niemand
sieht aus der Klappe raus auf den
Dachgepäckträger an die Lampe und dann
hieß es Endspurt die Polierer haben
poliert was das Zeug hält um irgendwie
an dem Tag noch fertig zu werden
wir haben die Digitaluhr und den
Zigarettenanzünder wieder ans Laufen
gebracht und die Frontschürze und die
Heckklappe montiert
und wenn das funktioniert und das
funktioniert dann war das jetzt gerade
der letzte Schritt im Umbau des neuen 44
Safari Rallye Dakar wie auch immer man's
nennen will die Lampen sind angelötet
die Leitung liegt nach hinten durch die
Bremsen sind entlüftet der ganze kleinen
scheiß der am Ende unheimlich wichtig
ist dass wir wirklich über die ganzen
Tage hinwegkommen ohne Probleme und wir
genug Licht haben ist in diesem Moment
fertig geworden und das sollte dann der
Umbau des neuen 44 gewesen sein und
deswegen gehen wir jetzt rein in den
carporn auf dem wir alle gewartet
[Musik]
so
erste
kleine Testung
komplett andere Sitzposition anderes
Lenkrad neue Boxen alles anders
es kommt ab Alter
na dann
[Musik]
es rollt wir rollen und alles
funktioniert oh Alter die Reifen sind so
fett und sitzt so viel höher wirklich
unglaublich was wir in 5 Tagen auf die
Beine gestellt bekommen haben die Leute
die wir später auf der Rally getroffen
haben konnten uns das auch nicht glauben
dass wir das in fünf Tagen umgesetzt
haben vergessen übrigens nicht den Kanal
zu abonnieren wenn ihr die Rally nächste
Woche nicht verpassen wollt ein riesen
Danke schön an Rennklasse bestehend aus
Markus Anton und mag die das Projekt
komplett mit mir geguckt haben die das
Auto mit mir geplant haben und in
kürzester Zeit umgesetzt haben also egal
was ihr an verrückten Umbauten für euer
Auto sucht ob ihr einen Oldtimer wieder
fit machen wollt ob ihr Service für ein
Wohnmobil braucht die Jungs kriegen
alles für euch hin und das in absoluter
Perfektion also hier noch mal persönlich
von mir Jungs ein riesen Danke schön
dass wir das Projekt so umsetzen konnten
um das Auto nicht zu behalten sondern an
einen von euch zu verschenken damit auch
noch mal ein kleiner Reminder als
Gewinnspiel Check die Links in der
Videobeschreibung stellt euch was bei
timec jeder Euro um das ist ein entry
oder macht beim Gewinnspiel Post über
die timec instagram-seite vielen vielen
Dank fürs zusehen ich hoffe euch gefällt
das Auto ich hoffe euch hat das Projekt
gefallen wenn ja lasst mir gerne ein
Like da wir sehen uns zur Rally wieder
macht's gut ciao
[Musik]